[Musique]
la colère n'est pas positive et se fera
rire et vous qu'est-ce que vous avez
pour moi je trouve que c'est mauvais
pour la santé
alors après celle du plus ennuyeux crise
de foi et tous alors quand je sens la
colère monte j'ai dis halte là c'est pas
bon alors c'est d'une certaine
philosophie de la vie vous avez des gens
nerveux sont toujours surexcité et nous
on est calme mais très calme
ce qu'on espère comme ça qu'on vivra un
peu plus longtemps
ta gueule
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas des gens à vous laisser
faire pas du tout pas du tout du tout
pas du tout tout ce qui concerne tout ce
qui comporte des injustices à me
convient pas au niveau de la conduite au
niveau de nos petites huttes de choses
ça me convient pas alors j'explose est
ce qu'il ya des limites quand même à vos
explosion oui quand même enfin des
limites
oui il y en a quand même je vais pas je
m'arrête pas à tout moment pour me
battre humbert il ya des moments où je
m'arrêterai volontiers pour la faire
votre dernière rumeur par rapport à un
automobiliste
c'est pas vieux il ya une quinzaine de
jours j'ai une grosse colère un
automobiliste qui m'a fait à la hauteur
de l'hôtel de ville qui m'a fait une
grosse queue de poisson
et en plus il s'arrête devant moi et
bloquent des sentiments gueule alors la
gym colère je suis descendu julie tu vas
vite remonté dans sa voiture parce que
sinon tu vas manger de la bouillie
pendant quinze jours avec une page
oui voilà ça c'est une colère mais je
l'avais la colère dans la rue par
exemple d'embouteillage vous face aux
administrations ne croyez pas que c'est
un petit peu sa lutte et oui alors là
évidemment ça ça arrive tout le temps on
pique des petites colères mais très très
mesurés parce qu'on appelle on a peur on
a peur un peu des chauffeurs de taxi moi
je me suis fait virer vous dise élevé le
ton up la porte et on à montréal j je
suis sorti j'ai dit c'est dégoûtant de
me faire ça et je suis sorti j'étais
tellement et bobby j'avais sorti c'était
une dame
j'avais sorti pas un colt de ma poche un
peigne voix a commencé à pousser les
cris et hop dehors bros
je suis sorti si vous aviez été nommé je
ne sais pas ça aurait dépendu de mon
caractère je ne puisse faire pas grand
chose
elle vous dit sortez de mumbai où tu vas
pas restée cramponnée de dons et de klm
opère
beurre dans la rue j'ai peur j'ai peur
qu'on me tape dessus tu vois puis avec
l'âge ça ne s'arrange pas et puis au
boulot alors là jamais de toute ma vie
je n'ai jamais on me sort des choses
énormes géante a sommé m
je fais comme si je vais pas entendu tu
vois comme si le mec avait fait avant
tout
s'il vous plaît
oui j'ai dit quelque chose est sûre
certains n'avaient pas dit qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont enflammés mais sur ma gueule
voyez ça dans la réalité je n'ai pas
fait j'ai pas quoi pourquoi parce que au
moment il ya une espèce de d'énervement
qui monte dans des situations comme ça
et au moment où je dois faire quelque
chose de physiquement violent est
quelque chose qui se bloque et en
général je n'arrive pas quelles sont les
situations qui nous font exploser ces
variables ccd situation mais c'est
surtout des gens les gens qui ont une
espèce de mauvaise foi évidente et qui
en gros se foutent de ma gueule et c'est
de la voir dans ce cas les lieux par
exemple ça peut être dans un garage un
garagiste qui essaie de nouveau de mon
tube et passe sous prétexte que je suis
une femme et qui comprend rien ça peut
mettre dans un magasin de vêtements une
fille qui essaie de lui absolument se
meut de me vendre quelque chose qui à
l'évidence ne va pas c'est n'importe
quelle situation c'est surtout la
manière de quelqu'un de s'y prendre
c'est surtout ça alors vous allez
reprendre ma voiture vous allez on a
réparé jusqu'à ce qu'elle marche nous
tairons voir fera l'embrayage et là vous
retrouverez votre voiture telle que vous
l'avez kouadio georges chouleur symbole
à réparer la première fois qu'est ce
qu'on est venu à ma mémoire et du tout
parce qu'elle marche toujours pas ça
m'est arrivé de taper sur des gens par
exemple
quelquefois dans même une tente ou de
mes tantes un jour qui m'avait beaucoup
énervé je vais sauter dessus
c'est un vrai plaisir
un vrai plaisir mais bon je vous sais
c'est plus sain plus libérateur de dcn
et rumeurs d'explosifs
oui c'est plus vrai puis c'est plus
drôle c'est moi sérieux vire je n'aime
pas me mettre en colère
et pourquoi pas ce que je trouve que
c'est un défaut de courtoisie mais vous
pensez pas que ça peut faire du bien
ah oui moi ça me ferait du bien et alors
pourquoi vous hésitez pour la personne
qui est en face uniquement
oui est ce qu'il vous arrive de vous
mettre en couleur tout seul alors oui
oui oui ça oui je rentre dans ma voiture
je vais me promener j'écris j'ai eu un
accident d'automobile il ya quelques
années j'étais piéton a été renversé par
une voiture et pendant assez longtemps
jeu
traverser la rue avec appréhension un
coup de frein de voitures suscité chez
moi des réactions physiques assez vive
mais je dois dire que le fait d'avoir eu
ce geste peut-être un peu vidéo m'a
détendu complètement et à atténuer
profondément les faits d'agressions que
j'avais subi en émotions d'un petit peu
tout de même que vous avez honte de
colère ont un peu de votre grande gueule
oui oui parce que ça ne se fait pas de
se mettre en colère çà ne sais pas ça
donne une image de soi que n'est pas une
bonne image aux rentes et un beau coup
l'image qu'on peut donner à l'extérieur
c'est à la réflexion que l'on se rend
compte du rôle de cette colère dans la
société d'une société où les dit tout à
l'heure je pense que les rapports oraux
sociaux sont aussi des rapports de force
qui ne citer que d'assez violente à
senna juste aux gens
donc il ya une nécessité d'avoir cette
capacité de réaction cette capacité de
révolte je crois que la soumission n'est
pas une bonne chose il faut une capacité
de révolte
comment le problème c'est comment la
discipline enfin je comprends pas madame
ça fait une heure que je suis là julie
ce chéquier je ne les ai pas eus bon
dieu le dira
[Musique]